Earlier, you avoided making a clear statement about why making money is not educational
.
It seems that it says in the poster that only upperclassmen can become teachers
Poster presentation
Everyone is a fine person.
The people of the world see it as a problem that students get involved
with money.The risks that arise from acknowledging your money-making, which is vulnerable to school pressure,
are too great.
People who don't know business fall behind those who do and lead a miserable life.
I don't want to become anything Is that education?
But in the end, you're just using the name of the school for your own benefit,
aren't you? I'm using it.
No, teacher, I want you to cherish the moment. There's no need to rush so much
. It's okay to become an adult.
I didn't ask for help with production costs, but instead proposed a joint project,
and Kanata made a decision.